[Music]
hey everyone this morning on Good
Morning America they showed us another
new clip from Avengers infinity war this
is an actual 23 second clip from the
movie so if you were trying to avoid any
spoilers about Avengers infinity war you
need to stop watching now still with me
okay here's the scene of Proxima
midnight and Corvus glaive fighting some
of the Avengers
[Music]
we don't want to kill you okay let's
break this down for starters we have
black widow fighting Corvus glaive you
can notice that black widow is fighting
Corvus glaive with Proxima midnight
slants when she hits Corvus glaive to
the ground you can see that he drops his
glaive Proxima midnight then attacks
Black Widow taking her spear without
even touching it
Captain America then rolls on the ground
picking up Corvus glaive glaive and
stops the attack of Proxima midnight on
Black Widow if you notice Proxima
midnight face here she has the same
facial expression that Thanos has and
the other trailer is clearly under
estimating how strong Captain America is
she then proceeds to fight Captain
America and Black Widow at the same time
until Falcon comes in and kicks her to
the ground right next to Corvus glaive
she then puts her hands on Corvus glaive
and tells him to get up in which he
replies I can't so a few things about
this scene if you think they're kind of
touchy-feely at the end well that's
because Proxima midnight and Corvus
glaive are married in the comics it also
seems like they severely underestimated
just how strong the Avengers were or at
least that's what they want us to think
I think that this scene is misdirection
given to us by Marvel so we don't know
what really goes on in the movie the
researchers have come out and stated
that fans have no idea what the actual
plot of infinity war will be and Corvus
glaive and Proxima midnight are not weak
Corvus glaive is the leader of the black
order or as they're calling it in the
movie the children of Thanos and Proxima
midnight is the most skilled fighter of
the children of Thanos so it seems like
they're not making the children of
Thanos as strong as they are in the
comics or perhaps the Avengers are a lot
stronger than we think they are or maybe
this is just a setup to make Fanta seem
even more powerful than we think he is
when he comes and defeats the Avengers
what do you all think about this scene
and what do you think is really going on
here let me know in the comments below
and let me know how excited you are to
see Avengers infinity war when it comes
out hit the thumbs up button if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe to my
channel to stay up-to-date on Avengers
infinity war thank you so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
you
[Music]